hello everybody how's it goin good
morning happy Monday hope everyone had
an amazing weekend we're back GameSpot
live is live and we're playing Star Wars
today Jordan is joining me and if you
guys haven't seen we do have some
awesome Star Wars stuff up at the
moments if you need some tips about this
game so far and we're just gonna start a
fresh game right from the beginning give
you guys a little looky loo game how's
it goin Jordan doing good doing good I'm
happy that I played a bit more of this
game over the weekend now knowing that I
was going to
I love the opening of
like
very just a bunch of junk
I was so very sad when I saw this for
the first time because I'm a huge Star
Wars the Clone Wars animated series man
like off all these clone warships being
taken apart
you look so good
listen I want upset your rhythm count
before the boss wants it work could be
good for us Yuri is chief
an error has been detected online
tonight all our clams I feel like this
is our sad you chair robot bosses that
are like directing these humans to do
all right let's go it's probably my
favorite thing about new games is the
way they do the cutting into the
gameplay I don't really like that and I
like a lotta games been doing that
recently and I'm always like so smooth
and we're gonna be streaming until 12:30
you guys currently eleven o'clock over
here in San Francisco what difficulty
are we playing on say I normally play on
master but I also figured that people
wouldn't want to see me like die every
2530 minutes pretty definitely very
Souls you to me look at that looks like
the dude oh well he isn't due to play a
joke on Gotham ages breaking her will be
big money
all right let's go
[Music]
we'll definitely try to get through as
much of this in the next 90 minutes or
so but it's beautiful like from start to
finish
hey you okay yeah we're on good place
already gonna have to find another way
no problem I'll improvise
[Music]
immediately you are not approved trash
Wow trash she's not proved trash I
relate to that so so this man all these
games just fighting for that like
release day what a Bob Jones welcome
back and of course everybody else in
chat thanks for joining us you guys
probably have had a chance to play it
over the weekend what do you guys think
so far how many times are you guys diets
be honest when I first played this I
died and like the first group of bots
like animals you fight or whatever I was
like whoa okay I need to relax I say the
animals in every Souls like game are the
worst part though like doesn't matter if
it's dark souls ashen coat vain or this
game if there's a dog like enemy it is
ruining my day
no matter how well like you guys need to
come out and say hi this time or
universe is watching from solution says
love you guys
I'm actually been
favorite team which i think is nearest
he can correct me if I'm wrong but I
want the state money that was very very
good probably one of the most beautiful
places I've been to like super clear
water it's gorgeous
[Music]
Kyle's a Klingon master died a lot it
happened
say I tried originally playing on Grand
Master and I was like this is this is
not good
I I'm not good enough for this
[Music]
oh my gosh select me it brings up baby
over there in the chat and all Lord baby
Yoda is the cutest thing of every scene
the whole mine it took me forever to
realize what people were talking about
the longest time when I finally watched
episode 2 I'm like ah this is what
everyone's been talking about I just
have a weakness for like baby versions
of characters I guess cuz I freaking
love me some baby Groot you know I'm
obsessed the internet was made for
sharing baby pictures giggle I like at
least still looks old somehow like a
baby
got it your turn
[Music]
dad says they did a great job in making
you feel like you're a Jedi I feel like
they definitely did especially in the
like struggle phase or you don't really
have that much going for you and you're
kind of learning and not you know
becoming it great like a better Jedi
yeah they'd only did that but you're
only overpowered if you're concentrating
like trying to do the smart thing like
you can't just stand there and just
dominate over so Jedi fighters coming
out 2020 probably not I so it'll get
here what I'm sure horniest flew this
but that on a place of glory those Jedi
real tragedy yeah I've always said they
couldn't all be traitors yeah maybe it's
gonna get a lot of good material ever
yep here we are scrapping these ship
food award just something to turn around
and make new ones
oh it's kind of weird we're just
destroying the Republic's our destroyers
with its name like this you take it off
this soggy Rock what makes you think I
want out of here
I Cal you're a young guy you don't end
up like me
eventually you kind of move on and live
your life find your destiny
hitting him with those heavy questions
because the young man what the Star Wars
universe interesting like I've never
once had like a teacher or I like my
parents come up but you got to go out
there
big place
now Bob Jones asks can you change and
choose your lightsaber color and you can
and you can also find like parts and
stuff
before it threw up again
but you'll also get born to be free
ordered
[Music]
kind of wonder why up in the deep down I
was bullied a prowling breath
[Music]
okay Matt Lauer around like enemies
house like shut up dude shut up we're
currently playing this on ps4 zero asked
if we were playing
I mean we're playing a place I'm moving
annex I was like reading his question
and speaking at the same time it wasn't
working very well there's no character
creation they can't make your own
character but you can customize cow you
can like buy a new Poncho's all the
different stuff to wear yeah
and it shows up in the cutscenes
whatever you're wearing - like that as
well as you're a lifesaver I love Kelly
it's like this dudes still talking about
this in public literally you don't have
to worry about me
this place
that's not safe
my patient
this'll be here I'm just gonna head back
to my place grab my bag tappers owes me
a favor
I heard he was up on the mousekedoer
yeah won't be seeing me for a while
Brock
okay
okay Cal
you just told him to go find his best
man so yeah great you do you he's like I
know what your destiny is now see I'm
from New York this is the first thing
you don't do on the training so you
don't do this you're talking about like
even more so here here it's way whereas
here actually I've seen people too small
asleep on the train like holding their
cell phone oh and their hands and I'm
just staring and I'm like are you are
you asking someone to steal a pair of
you because that's what it seems like
what you're doing
brah wait up brah come back I need you
are you going
I've been linked to many horror games
lately and this prayer definitely
freaked me out a little bit just cause
it was dark and scary and not cuz they
actually stick
[Music]
I love that part I was gonna wait till
you turn before a key combination like
[Music]
Prentis mark well I'm listenin master
trusts only in the force
but a violent teaching method gave my
word before I slam you in everybody oh
snap the fuzzy a contraband inspection
our armor is so now looks so sleek nice
where the cosplayers at and need this
IRL I say I guarantee you came out a
bunch of people started working on it
looks so good and it doesn't look like
feasible we seek a dangerous fugitive
this is no calm and Anna kissed but a
day I love the Nightsisters just in the
background just stalking like which one
is it please just tell me turn over this
traitor will result in a charge of
sedition turn yourself in or everyone
present shall face summary execution
well then this escalated quickly I think
it's time someone came forward
I I've been working on this keep a long
time way before the war
we refit and rebuild ships best in the
galaxy
then came the Empire and engineers
became scrappers the workers just
started getting warped he also has that
on him all the time and knowing it we're
just too afraid to say it
to the Empire we're all just expendable
yes I've found the Jedi did you find do
you know
I was actually like courtesy that
dropped you get away I actually love the
things they say when you buy it family
you don't need to call this in
nope yeah I loved all of the dialogue
between the Subaru
[Music]
[Music]
now when you lay it into a big group of
them sometimes delts are arguing with
each other a little bit like someone hit
you get so frustrated one way out you go
get him no you keep moving
we are playing on PC with an Xbox
controller just arrest instead
[Music]
wolf horsepower I know
actually really enjoy the little puzzle
like make you think romance like
like stop this
[Music]
Messiah said parrying is definitely key
in this game 100% that at it I used the
force to just freeze everyone and go man
because Acura I played like me oh but
I'm not good at it oh okay so you're
obviously a professional here
do you like just like the side seminar
or the role more sometimes are like the
role hell hurts me more than it helps me
try to do it live the role less
oh yeah that's true midlife crisis
Fitness says once you get poorest push
the game gets much better yeah I would
we'll push everyone off the edge first
before I like start cover got to move in
between versus
now I can make the farther one I can i
definitely died on this right when I
first played sir because I
underestimated the power of the Blazer
being about her and I tried to look like
take it slow go behind you everywhere
oh I love that too that like babies will
we destroy each other so great you shot
a couple yo and even like the monsters
will did the stormtroopers
well this bat
the only way is up Bob Jones asked
so is he a Padawan when the Jedi fell
[Music]
I say he looks like
assuming this probably
right consists is set in the Star Wars
universe
shortly after Episode three ribbon
the ethically
like have a real marathon like watch the
movies and then play this and then
continue the mini speaking to each other
like they're traveling so quickly the
boys
great linear business look at his hair
malicious lot
[Music]
open up Aranda and fast
he says so many contenders for game of
the year
[Music]
oh I love oh wait a little girl oh my
god oh the outer worlds and outer wiles
[Music]
we're multitasking Firefox a
[Music]
and say once you've seen what the last
level of this name is the first level
becomes
train stopped
[Music]
now this can't be good
totally calculated
automatic the word here the bed
[Music]
yeah there's definitely broke your tie
I love the robots out it's like what's
going on
great don't whack
[Music]
I recognize that stunts perhaps you've
had some training after all
with your master pattern so when I can't
what judge I gave in life so that you
might need
otter voice is so creepy I love it it's
perfect
[Music]
horse powers are cheating I don't have
fine yet not fair I always was
forgetting to do that really recovering
quick I was eating so much unnecessary
damage
[Music]
she's so Chih wrong forever
[Music]
okay
[Music]
reddit's access unblockable Oh
[Music]
somebody else
I got some of your help I feel like
variation gotten hit once so she can
hold that for a young promising padawan
come a few
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
hold that night while they try to get
control here
[Music]
okay shut that thing off
grab some seat great please don't
accidentally stabbed me with thanks for
the help
who are you people my name is C agenda
and this is my captain priest rightis
are you doing yeah the man is my ship
but you better pay attention to this
lady here and so who are you
kal Estes who was that back there
an imperial Inquisitor she's a force
user hunting Jedi survivors and now that
she knows who you are she will not stop
until she destroys how do you know so
much and why'd you help me
we tracked Imperial communications we
heard the inquisitors we're heading to
Brock so we made our move yeah
what's the bounty on Jetta these days
anyway that's gratitude for you
can I get it you've been surviving on
your own for so long that it's
impossible to trust anyone
and it's what's kept you alive but this
is about something bigger than just
surviving like what
like rebuilding the Jedi Order
you too
anybody else oh we're not good enough
for you Jedi Council
they're gone
so I'm all you've got
captain set a course for Pagano
I
in the meantime try and relax
go you're safe
for now
whew all right we made it off of that
planet that soggy Rock as prophets say
there we go that desk you were talking
in your sleep
why were you standing over me listening
all right oh [ __ ] yeah
so side note if I was a part of this
universe I would never be shooting no
laser gun at anybody with a lightsaber
ever because they definitely I'm gonna
reflect that right back into my face and
yeah but she said no no to me in my
videos
right
oh yeah can't play those smooth smooth
jams get degrees now I got work to do
we'll find that Wow
oh there we go weird
I'm actually so glad everyone's been
enjoying the game you know you know how
life is nowadays everybody wants to hate
on everything response had a great
career this generation like a few months
after ps4 and Xbox one came out they
come out with titanfall we follow that
up with titanfall 2 and then 8x legends
and fall in order within the same year
right when the console generations about
to end like they have rocked that's all
I wrote it years ago
Bellator isn't such an object and
witness events connected to it you feel
it's history it's an echo and the force
from the object many Jedi have that
skill how would you know that I was once
a Jedi but not anymore
do I know you master
Gerald DePaul it was a true guardian of
the Republic he was a hero
listen
something happened to me during the
purge
I survived but my connection to the
force is damaged when I meditate if I
let my guard down I lose control and
it's like I'm back in that moment what
you survived yeah
and you're not alone but anymore kind of
love the whole PTSD storyline they have
kind of going on in this game maybe
don't go into it super heavy because
it's it's like you were a kid and you
saw a bunch of soldiers try to kill you
yeah you're probably gonna have some
like mental and emotional damage after
that this is Fergana a Jedi I new
discovered it before the purge you won't
find it on any Maps the Empire doesn't
know this place exists now so what's the
plan we hide out here we're done hiding
kal see that structure over there
I believe that vault holds the key to
rebuilding the Jedi Order but it
requires someone strong in the force to
pass its test since you're not a Jedi
anymore that's why you need me I know
you does Mikey and I'm not really sure I
trust you but we have a common enemy and
a common cause I'll share more of my
plan after you reach the vault but until
then there's someone here I think you
should beat
may the force be with you not so sassy
to each other
[Music]
so pretty
it's all like rundown okay still afraid
I'm looking for a Jedi that if there's
already one here what is here need me I
do really love that they kept even like
the slow wipe transition was like that
when I first saw the movies those
transitions like stuck in my brain
forever I was like wow they were
committed to this wipe transition don't
need to know how it works I know how it
works
hey Dee Dee one cute I'm Cal yeah I'm
okay I'm just looking for someone no not
you searching for Ed and Jedi I think
hold on you know the guy wait up
[Music]
did you just slice that Thanks
yeah I want one I love that the back of
meeting one's head the lights will
change you're managing on whoever's
which I must be waiting I was really
hoping that there would be a mode in
this game where you could just turn off
the UI and you had to rely on you like
let you know if you were about to die I
miss dead space
it's basically what I'm saying
[Music]
they literally don't let you out of this
until you do all of these you must
experiment
you must prove to us you know how to
make this map work Messiah said don't
forget to run beneath of the ship and
remember it later I think there's some
goodies there any ideas I say there's a
lot of videos you can get here once you
get a counseling for bt1 and a black
horse push for Cal that's me how'd you
know that would work
[Music]
Raphael said counties more outfits and
heat those ugly ponchos some of those
ponchos our names all of them just like
back at the scrapyard
[Music]
okay that's pretty brief okay wait I can
help you with that
no like how you let me was going to keep
going on that broken leg well this comp
link is busted but this should help you
get moving from now you guys ever worn
apart the show alright let me just throw
that out there because until you
actually worn one you can't appreciate
it from South Texas yeah that's right my
turn Broncos okay Oh find some nice ones
you're out way out of this place
oh yeah sorry can customize a little bit
should we stick with the blue or go to a
green lightsaber we don't have any other
pieces at the moment I switched to the
green room and I played just cuz I had
the option to and I was like alright
let's go green folks bTW that's a little
small to me
don't worry I'll buy my own way out
tight fit but this should work those
vines look like they read somewhere hope
they're sturdy
[Music]
Pancho's are mad comfy too and they're
not super heavy so you don't sweat
[Music]
you're like seeing the beginning again
makes me fall in love BT even more like
stim they're full of surprises like
how's the total stranger and he's broke
cares so much about him that's better
thanks a little droid okay let's try
this again
hop on board oh my gosh
a beedi one and baby Yoda that can all I
need in my life Reina
well killing remember never known a
forgetful droid can't argue with that
are you going so what was it like a part
of his audio hughes for boxes the entire
game at some point you're like you know
where he's going he's going to search
for a new life favorite part or a poncho
that's what I need to go I can feel it
darío says this game is fabulous thank
you very definitely you know among all
of my friends who are like super Star
Wars fans they all love you not
everywhere we've been amazing how was I
getting along without you is all time
all these years this is how I feel about
like smartphones in Google Matt make you
late where what was I doing before I
love Google Maps like I remember that
there was once a point in my life right
didn't use Google Maps but what what did
I do
yeah thank you thank you remember those
days of MapQuest we had to print out
your instructions
take them with you and still get lost
did they make no sense yeah
Raphael said I heard bt1 was based on a
puppy that is adorable
if that's true and I totally see it I
want to be suppressed at all don't touch
me who would do that
like be attached to me all the time real
animals identically are like alright I'm
bored of you I mean when they went love
they come back I don't know why I'm
standing like I've done this already in
my place he just jumped there - ploy
yeah Bob we changed our lightsaber
degree in just cuz we could I can't do
anything with this what you find
but yeah that move hasn't been added yet
to our skill set just yet
[Music]
you know because it responds the enemy
is every time you rest
I found myself like really pushing it
and waiting as long as possible to rest
I appreciate I know
no bt1 no time to scan see something in
there again I like a lady this faster
yes the path is difficult it may seem
impossible but with persistence and the
force as your ally you will overcome any
obstacle you will master any path now do
what you must to reach me
[Music]
well I could just jump right now not
that easy young paddle
now reach my position resistance and the
forces my ally just remembering old
tricks you didn't show me that shortcut
again I know where the shortcut is I
think a lot of people in the chat who
have either just finished or they're
like halfway through I say it's not a
super long game
this area was used for meditation by
someone familiar with the Jedi Order
[Music]
yeah you can get really parkour in this
game sometimes I run on the wall into a
side and then you jump in you swing on a
rope into another wall or some vines
like yeah and then you win in the middle
of a pack full of like crazy like grams
or something and then they all just kill
you when it's me playing there's one
stage where I literally like was kind of
backing away from one and back into
another one and then both of them were
just going in oh man I enjoy the puzzles
in this game the ones I played so far I
have a very Legend of Zelda my very
obvious puzzles but it's fun like some
tomb raider vibes a little bit too
Parker hard for Parker Gracie their open
world not more Metroidvania than open
world we're not finished yet okay okay
you probably would have won
open the door cow
use the horse can't build a controller
baby
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
I forgot how uncharted happy the first
part of this game was all just explore
well done whether you like helping you
get a grab things you can do so far and
gained access to the vault and this
recording one of many encrypted logs
stored in the droid I am master ela
Cordova I may not know your name but I
know your purpose the fate of the Jedi
Order lies in your hands this place this
vault is a sacred temple built by a
vanished civilization known as the
Zephyr meditating here I was granted a
premonition through the force a vision
of doom and you didn't tell any Jedi
holocron locations of young force
sensitives throughout the galaxy I have
you will find the inner chamber of the
vault but also another test I can only
trust this hologram to someone who has
followed my path and understands seek
out the hidden tombs of the three sages
and learn to perceive the mysteries of
the force as the Zephyr once did in this
droid you will find everything you need
to succeed on this journey go to the
sepal homeworld there you will find
peace in the eye of the storm
good luck Jedi and may the force be with
you
I first sure thought the first time I
was playing this game that he was about
to do it what condos for ever and I'm
like what what Disney's really doing
some grasses yes you were the someone I
was supposed to meet no he's like told
you just sat down on that water like
nothing I know right I'd be so
uncomfortable you know I've been alone
for like dude your butts gonna be on wet
for like the next 40 minute I'm just
hiding it's no way to live I've heard
yet I orange right maybe see what was
right
maybe were done hiding
hey you want to meet some friends of
mine God he's so cute and he's just like
a bunch of little beeps and wheat like
wheezy mechanical noises and it's all
adorable so great I think I found what
you wanted me to see sounds like you did
we'll be waiting
goodbye before hold that thought while I
ran past because I am a coward
we've got more places to go I can hear
them right behind me
yes jumping
[Music]
my friend it appears the Zephyr had some
interest in death strange weird you have
to have any sort of fascination well we
got about 35 minutes left on this dream
I feel like the objective is uh is fo
but what can you get out of door behind
what in my playthrough I went should be
a lot quicker than the way in SA you
went to correct way but you can go to
Dathomir first and struggle against much
harder enemies but I can do that I can
do that for 30 minutes oh those are so
cute like squirrel bunnies save you come
back here with the forest Bush you can
recruit one to join you on your ship
people in the chat want us to go to
Dathomir
alright you passed the test so you knew
about bt1 come on board we'll talk
inside
nobody answers questions around here
maybe one this is that is bTW one he's
with us idea how hard it is to get oil
state really found something better out
there than this droid no calm down
breeze he did tell us kal
the vault was built by an ancient
civilization called the zepho a Jedi
named you know Cordova hid something
inside of it what did he hide inside a
holocron from the archives it contains a
list of force-sensitive children the
next generation of Jedi I knew it Oh
Cordova you old fool you knew him yes a
long time ago yeah I was his apprentice
Cordova was a loner that little droid
and I are probably the only ones that
know about pagano oh wait a minute wait
a minute Oh what oh it stores
information but only accessible to Jedi
hang on I think I have one around here
you just have a just color like one of
the rarest artifacts in the Star Wars
universe chillin on a shelf hey Cal I
could have told you earlier that obi-wan
I just chose not to rebuild the Jedi
Order and defeat the Empire okay no
problem let's get it except the holocron
is hidden deep inside the ball and to
get it we have to follow Cordova's path
he mentioned something about the planet
Dathomir and as Zeppo homeworld
alright well where are we going now I'm
just asking because I was thinking too
maybe making some food weird sounds good
I need to know something
how come you no longer a Jedi I had an
experience that changed my perspective
so I cut myself off from the force but
you still want to rebuild the order I
believe that rebuilding the order is the
best chance we have against the Empire
what do you believe I believe I can't
keep hiding from the Empire so I don't
really have a choice hell as long as
you're alive you will always have a
choice this plan is so diesel II flawed
like you know if we just had more Jedi
we could probably stop the Empire and
all those troopers they have them like
do you not remember how all the Jedi
died in the first place
oh snap Randall in the chances got this
game for his birthday happy birthday
birthday's on Saturday yes great hate
sitting around like this hope you've
been enjoying it
hi inside a probably should have gone
any courts get that a stim pack upgrade
but we won't try to do the surprise
needles we got this I am staying put on
the Manus once we arrived red sunlight
cannot be good for your skin his place
used to be home to a powerful cabal of
force fielders known as the Nightsisters
they use the force what I know
these boots of themselves their powers
focused on deception illusion
manipulation sounds like someone I used
to know during the Clone Wars the
Nightsisters made a deal with a Sith
Lord who betrayed their trust in the end
they were nearly wiped out 81 definitely
it was a damn yeah we should be careful
no one no no to tell me twice
like how he checks around first and then
cow
oh snap all the planets look so
different and so cool oh of course
gonna be friendly definitely not but I
won't forget to go up there and live yes
a few just ignore you think someone in
chat was asking if we were gonna get the
double saber come here certainly try
Hey music silent and he's like finally
when I played any time BT like hopped
off my back I'm like rage on where we
going
where what are we skin whatever you want
such a sucker guy here yeah
well flowers brings up a good point cuz
it was something I was struggling with -
he said for his own personal opinion he
feels like there's too much platforming
and some of the platforming elements are
not very well polished and lack control
I feel like the only moments I really
really felt that way it was like when
you're sliding and you have to catch a
rope I would feel like I'm always right
on the rope and who doesn't grab the
rope and then I fall my dam is forbidden
- you leave at once well I'm afraid I
can't do that but perhaps we could help
each other
you see I easy I'm not your enemy is
your to actually say other ways hold on
I'm not here
[Music]
right your guard nice there so so much
more difficult than scout troopers but
yeah in terms of the platforming those
were the instances where I was kind of
struggling through like I try to jump
off from sliding to the rope not work
sometimes even I was like there but
aside from that everything else was
great to go like the wall running I felt
it was pretty good yeah
I remember correctly there is someone up
here my brother's what difficulty
everyone I think we're on Jedi Knight
wanted to have an enjoyable playthrough
streams where did you get the black
outfit right now yeah keep shooting
[Music]
hold that
[Music]
whoa sneak attack nothing I need one
stop dancing around
will you I am so weak
[Music]
no camping these campers with punished
hi friends why don't you shoot at me
again heartbeat I can hear Cal's
heartbeat in my headphones shoot me me
and I like catching on he's like maybe
this bow and arrow is a bad idea now I
think I do think the comment is good
it's just a different piece you know I
mean like some people like being it but
it just hack and slash like I came
freshly off of playing through last
year's battle board so I was very much
in like a ham mindset when I started
playing this sounds like okay I gotta
slow down and really be calculated here
damn it Cal I need you to jump higher
for just half a second there we go
when you're walking on these little
poles and stuff you just hold for it I
was like trying to move my body left and
right to balance
just in case there anyways camp around
these core I know I have to go back
around I have to get on the other side
of that door but at least all the
enemies are gone even though my health
is very very very very low yeah I can
probably take one more hit before I it's
fine everything's well everything's okay
okay God you are a Jedi and I need you
to work with me here
[Music]
oh my goodness now please there we go
[Music]
oh there's guy down there yeah
oh there's two guys down there yeah it's
definitely the way where there's more
and Wow can't catch us
where's the door where's the door I just
need it the shortcut to be opened
powerful brothers I didn't think he was
gonna jay-z I thought he's gonna stay in
[Music]
your campers and chasers
is there going to be a community Friday
this week good question
Ben and John linka get some super super
busy lately we've had a lot going on
hopefully we will it's not maybe you
know I'll try to help you might want to
take over their segments but I mean you
guys have been missing community Brady
yeah I would definitely recommend for
anybody looking to get this game to if
it's within your means to get it on PC
but I feel like it looks and runs your
best on PC I was struggling a little bit
I was playing on xbox and there were
definitely some moments of struggle with
like loading and things like that so fun
there's just at least a better quality
of life on key scenes there's a black
Evi once again oh my gosh I probably
look so cute
wow this guy is just a very skilled
Romanians yeah well I forgot about that
guy into court that was like a headshot
dang see you trying to rush it down and
it just goes downhill it's like you have
to be cautious and calculated in every
single moment sometimes you just want to
like I say I have been able to once
before just run all the way yeah like I
personally don't have a PC so you know I
can't get the PC version also can't
afford a PC right now so I will I will
gladly just play on my console version
but just aim like if it's within your
means to actually get it on PC I would
recommend it
alright Kalyn now the time Cal that was
not the time to mess up well I need you
to work with me cow cow believe oh great
stay over there all right we need yellow
we need to lure them back outside you
don't have real zing and they're talking
that hot trash you don't have real power
we didn't need that extra bit of flair
they're cops wing and I was like damn it
I miss having double jump
[Music]
we got this car crying last night in
fruiterers down bad these combos like
the tag-team teamwork really makes the
dream work right here do they really let
you meditate yep
it's like in GTA you're like go into the
pit into the garage paint your car but
you know what I'm just gonna pick my car
and then all as well
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
get out of here
all right three less people chance yes
FL is a part of like the story objective
but you do analog this world didn't go
here too in their place you know good if
you can get it but definitely a little
bit of a higher difficulty oh this is
the guy give us all of that back and
your life while we're at it let me t1
play in the box
like pong all right all right now we're
good
just got it yeah see Cal we just needed
you to be at the first five minutes Oh
Sam you had just done this earlier we
were a team
we were a team in this in like every
game anything that has like a death from
above say food love it
all right a little bit of patience why
can't you have done that the first time
we did Similac but we died so yes I see
Matt the resident Nightsister doctor
unlike most you alive
one lightsaber there now don't hide it
that would explain your survival who are
you
you know what to fear mr. traveler
nobody answers question distinct
cultures they had philosophies just tell
you the Nightsisters I study many things
but yes that night sister she was only a
child and walk into this world she had
to watch her whole family perish but do
you know about this ruins agent beyond
belief the night sister and her warrior
kin were seduced by the power that lurks
with him it avoid the road or suffer the
same thing
[Music]
I can break I can't jump that high
yeah yeah but there is the lightsaber
upgrade right here a boom
as requested by Chas doubling zeros
[Music]
I feel like this is where it's like
veering off course a little bit to get
although I felt like if I had that thing
I would definitely accidentally chop my
leg off just saying although it's super
cool
my limbs they're in danger
[Music]
yeah I would have accidentally popped
the other one let me pass keep your due
to yourself oh yeah check it out it's
not actually
someone was drawn to something here
energy from the ruins must rest
right Mathias he says being
accident-prone might not be beneficial
for a Jedi Knight that's returned yeah
I'd never last
Wow I didn't even see the rope there I
was like wow don't overshoot a cow you
overshoot it every time don't do it this
time
there we go my sister survived something
about her is familiar stay right there
blow me and eat me oh my gosh
oh those combos though it's okay we're
closed
it's so it's like I don't normally
unlock the double bladed lightsaber this
early in the game because you don't have
any eventually you unlock the skill
where you can use a lightsaber throw
where you throw it in a circle around
you turn yourself like into a beyblade
I'm like this this is cool yeah
Peg's ready like a fella like literally
fleeing these giant bed bugs get away we
have what we came here for start the
ship glad you made it back in one piece
there were some close calls out there
yeah please tell me nothing follows you
home kid I hope not now we left the
bedbugs outside and hopefully made up
the bomb the place is not where to
on our way to Zephyr uh yeah I know
right it was really fun having
ammunition in the studio last week we
actually played uncharted so very much
something new to look at pretty much
enjoy that shame is super fun I've
always liked it when I was younger I
used to pour through every piece I could
find at the Jedi archives did you
critique them too I admired them when I
became a seeker I'd like to see a few in
person so many different cultures in the
galaxy and each one had their own unique
works of art it was breathtaking
it seems like that would be very
different quietly have different
versions of what bar smells like Mathias
is when beautiful skills has to be the
double down to land yeah something
strange those winds are interfering with
our comms a Cordova mentioned something
about peace in the eye of the storm I
can just make out a settlement in the
middle of it then we have to get there
copy that does that mean like this
particular storm like this um never yeah
unless one picks up like a force field
you tell that bucket of balls to keep
his opinion to a tale I'm sure watch
your mouth under don't talk to bt1 like
that I'm like so defensive no one
deserves back video here
huh perfect landing
breezy money baby but I'm still getting
a lot of interference oh it's gonna take
me a minute to get them back up I can
see their signs in Cordova in the
meantime good I'll be in touch once I
crack this oh snap anonymous donut
dropping combos in the chat the slash
slash Porsche push have you hit and then
freeze best congressman is fo forceful
it makes jumping rope is much easier yes
it doesn't like but don't know much away
my my woes of missing the ropes
everything else I am believing their
teachings to be important
I too was intrigued by the mysteries of
our galaxy you better get moving
there's a lot to learn here good luck
oh wait I was thinking the other thing
it never means this won't still really
get that Billy Payne no spoilers
[Laughter]
all right we've got about five minutes
left of history and I'm so glad we got
to see this farm to breaking get out of
here
hey pd-1 remember those TV shows like
gladiator something they have that one
game when you use to stick to like push
the other person off of them that's what
that's reminding you yeah
No I need some meds b1
[Music]
who extra light
[Music]
mother used this fabric to keep her
child warm you want to run from
something stink rate should be thanks
Petey one that is very true anonymous
done it you definitely cannot spam
attacks I'm like a bigot power
eventually you get strong enough where
you can but it takes hello can you hear
me the Empire they found Zeppo if they
were following the Mantis we would have
been swarmed already did they be looking
for the tombs
let's hope not just got our comms
working I'll try the same workaround to
crack into there
my cow let them shoot the monster yeah
sure 81 yeah this stage is where the
boundary is really funny
yeah you got great job guys you tried
Vega bodied yeah it's like after hanging
out on Dathomir a couple minutes he says
oh yeah easy peasy
totally I can't hold my freaking Jedi
then I can do everything later we are on
Jedi Knights difficulty donut
walking my blow over reinforcements are
on the way you're not I want to do voice
acting but just for like I feel like
that would be the funnest job
ooh two points Oh actually it's 12:30
yes that is actually got a wrap of our
playthrough today we hope that you guys
enjoyed what you saw ap did go ahead and
pick the game up it's out for Xbox ps4
and PC it's a lot of fun especially for
Star Wars fans and even people who
aren't like dart die-hard Star Wars fans
I feel like it's really fun to yeah so
hope you guys enjoyed it thank you so
much happy Monday it's the start of the
week but don't worry guys you got this
we can get through this together
11:00 a.m. Pacific time every weekday
that's where you can see us and tune
into GameSpot live I hope you had a
great time and have a good day